I can't speak for all academia but for
anthropology as a discipline within
academia I think there's this tension
right now where there's a desire for
anthropologists to be more engaged and
sort of a kind of activist to
anthropology and that overcomes the
distancing of effect of sort of
observing and participant observation
and theoretical understandings of human
life but this there was this recent you
know story in The New York Times about
anthropologists now being embedded in
combat units in Afghanistan I'm not sure
if they're also doing it in Iraq but it
was in Afghanistan and it was a strategy
to try and embed an anthropologist in
every combat unit and it raised all
these debates for the Academy because on
the one hand people were saying we'll
finally someone saying that this
knowledge that we generate is useful in
these very practical ways and conflict
had often been reduced sixty percent
winner and anthropologists have been
with the combat unit and sort of just
known what was going on you know terms
of the sort of local your tribal
dynamics but on the other hand you know
if anthropologists are so dependent on
the goodwill of people and letting a
complete stranger and come into their
community and live there and observe
their lives that if there's even a
shadow of a doubt that an anthropologist
somehow you know linked to the US
government in certain areas of the world
I think that undermines the
anthropological project anywhere so I
think for the for the Academy it is it's
this tendency to both you know stick in
the ivory towel and and and justify that
by saying you know we can't get involved
because the moment we get involved we
implicated in these things and then this
tendency to say well how do we make this
knowledge that we generate relevant and
useful to people in
need in your lives and as a graduate
student it's just you know this phase of
graduate schools i'm doing coursework
haven't yet started my own research i'm
very much of the theoretical distance
devil before i have to actually going
sort of get my hands dirty i think it's
really in that field work experience
that a lot of these things have worked
out so anthropology is unusual in that
sense within the Academy because it does
have that field work two years of field
works are built into your academic
experience it and forces you to grapple
you know and go out there and engage
with people and so it's an like
sociology which is you know much more
statistical sort of quantitative based
social science so it's very unusual in
that sense but it's still struggles with
finding a balance between those first